there's me five society solid could come
yeah I know not much flavin I mean we've
been getting the ball to an outfit as
much as we can there really think
[Music]
hi I'm Joey bar and this is sport Bible
meets in the play-off final for QPR's
we certainly went to favourites going
into the final I don't think we were
expected to get to the final so to get
to the final was an achievement and then
to go down to ten men and to score with
the last kick of the game and was
incredible and it's obviously difficult
when I'm trying to kick ten lumps of
shades out if you're on a Saturday to
become your best mate how so you don't
really make friends with the opposition
you become quite insulating in terms of
your Football Club so best mate in
football great relationships with
virtually everybody apparently I think
as I got a bit more mature and developed
as a person as a player I was able to
forge great lazy chips I mean they still
speak to Tommy and it's got a
half-filled been me you know certainly
up there Lee I think I found my the
perfect spot and becoming a good player
and a good teammate to be along and I
don't think that's always been the case
across my career journey there's been
times when I've been probably very very
difficult to be alongside
oh that's off question I've been looking
away for some good managers but
obviously I think I'd have to say the
most recent one Shawn died she just I
was at a good stage in my career in
terms of I think where I was at
emotionally in terms of a team
environment and and he's obviously a
great manager I think you go on to be an
even better manager as time progresses
sometimes you meet a manager he might be
a good manager but emotionally or
whatever it is you're at in your life he
isn't the right manager for you but
obviously might be the right manager for
12 other people in the dressing room but
he isn't fit 6 so I don't really believe
in bad I believe there is good there is
better out there but I think everybody
has strengths and weaknesses so I've
learned that in the offseason because 34
years before that I fought I can't wait
to stop playing football so I can start
enjoying some of this money away and
then I can go on climb Everest and all
these mad things I'd always wants to do
and actually when I can do them now I'm
like
I don't want to do any of them I'd
always fantasized about going skiing
because it was every contract that I
couldn't go skiing and now I can't go
skiing
I haven't even entertained the idea of
going ski why I wanted to do a podcast
is to have conversations with people in
almost feel like it gives the pass and
accidentally the opportunity to almost
like be a fly on the wall in between a
conversation with two people and cut my
all the nonsense let's just have a
conversation let's cut away that crap
questions I think lots of people get
asked which I've run into quite a lot
not in this interview but I do run into
it quite a lot and I think I wouldn't
have asked him that question so I think
what would I have asked them you have
played with it definitely Peter
Schmeichel Engel even though played with
him and he was later incredible
goalkeeper an elf is the best player
I've played with I think not even no
one's come even close to it didn't
really enjoy playing with Kevin all love
playing Kevin all on that at Newcastle
defenders who can a defense been me I
think it's incredible defender
apparently very very underrated defender
I'll have to quote myself from there
when I it's 55 aside see solid good pump
yeah I know not much flavor and I mean
we'd be getting the ball to an elf or as
much as we can they really think but I'd
like to be in the trenches with that
group I mean and then we just let me go
if he turns off he wins games yeah